hello everyone and welcome to round 16
of the 1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament as you've seen in my previous
video after three consecutive wins
Fischer again hits a draw against Cuban
international master sir Guerra and now
he faces Mongolian international master
today when we - man if that's how you
pronounce Mongolian names I'm not sure
but he did in 1965 he did become the
first Mongolian international master he
won the demon goalie in chess
championship three times and he
represented Mongolia six times in the
Chess Olympiad and and this is one of
the tournaments that he is playing
excellent chess as in round one which
woman defeated Samuel Reshevsky and he
continued his winning streak up until
around four so after after three rounds
of the hamid america inter-zonal
tournament which woman here was the sole
leader of the tournament now he faces
the Bobby Fischer he has the white
pieces and before we check out the game
I did prepare a nice photo challenge for
you also a nice photo to promote chess
but it's more of a movie question so
best of luck to everyone who are the two
chess players in the photo here there
you have it best of luck to everyone
it's it's an old game so I don't know
how many of you would know this but you
know if you consider statistics you know
what ages watch my channel I'm pretty
sure you will know this one so best of
luck to everyone now let's check out the
game each woman has the white pieces and
he opens with efore and Fisher a year
again goes for Knight to f6 he already
won one game with aliens defense so why
not try it again
'if I've you know everything according
to how I imagined this should be played
Knight to d5 b4 we have d6 attacking the
central pawn c4 9th to b6 and in the
previous game he captures on d6 was
played here we have f4 and we have the
four pawns attack Fischer goes for a
bishop to f5 and now Knight the c3 by
Ottoman it's worth noticing that g4 you
know you can't go for something like a
five pounds attack
Bishop to e4 will be deadly the Yurok on
h1 is under attack
after you defend this would Knight to f3
only move you will get captures and now
you will either capture with the D pawn
where black will capture the Queen and
then grab your knight or you will
capture with D F pawn but then simply
Bishop captures on f3 Queen captures and
Queen captures on d4 and black will have
an excellent game here so after Bishop
to a5 we have Knight to c3 now guarding
the e4 square no this is the g4
definitely could be an idea but black
immediately plays ecigs and prevents any
such ideas because now g4 would be met
with Queen to h4 check and the white
will of course be lost here so II 6 we
have Bishop to e3 Bishop to e7 preparing
the castle tonight to have three and now
castles eke actors on b6 c captures on
d6 + b3 now a nice solid move improving
White's
a bone structure and the Fischer goes d5
we have c5 advancing the pawn Knight
night 6 to d7 Bishop to d3 now offering
to trade bishops and Bishop captures
Queen captures and b6 now it would be I
mean if you could pull something off
like f6 and e5 this would be excellent
for black but it's it's not possible
because white would go f5 here and after
you push and after an exchange is made
here then your d5 point is undefended
and after all is said and done you would
simply lose upon here but you know what
it does have a firm grip against d5
square and this should definitely be
challenged sometime in the future
b6 we have pawn capture some b6 Queen
captures and b6 and now we have castles
by Ottoman and Fischer goes Queen to a
sex immediately offering to trade
Queen's Queen to d1 vitamin declines the
Queen trade Knight to c6 and the now
comes the Knight to e5 Fischer captures
Knight see captures on e5 f captures on
e5 and now rotate to c8
attacking with immense night and uncie
three rook to c1 defending and now f6
fish are finally at
which means strong central bone
structure he captures an f6 Knight
captures on f6 and h3
to be four now with a double attack
against the Ottomans c3 Knight Knight to
a4 offering a rope trade rook captures
and now Bishop characters
Queen captures was also possible but
after Queen captures perhaps he didn't
enjoy rook to c8 and then you you have a
lot of things to consider here tonight
the c5 is definitely an option but then
you get Bishop captures pawn captures
and not even capturing an a2 but rather
a five starting a central pawn strong
and also queen capture Sonny 2 remains a
threat so this would be very enjoyable
for black to play but again after rook
to CIT you could consider moving the
Queen Queen d1 and then after something
like nice to e4 queen g4 and the Queen
to d6 but again black will be solid in
in any of these variations so I have to
look the c1 a rather Bishop captures on
c1 is played we have 90 to e4 offering a
trade of rooks rook captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop to f4 Bishop to
d6 we have Queen to g4 and now Bishop
captures on f4 Queen captures on f4 and
Queen to d6 Fischer offers now a trade
of Queens with Queen captures and the
Knight captures so we reached this
endgame where the material is completely
equal to two pawns on the Kings side the
differences Fischer has an advantage two
points against one on the in the center
of the board and Whitman has an
advantage two points against one on the
Queen side so it's pretty much an equal
endgame let's see how they play it out
here Knight to c3 was played which is
the best move you can't go something
like King to have to e3 to protected the
d4 pawn because after king f2 Knight to
a5 is coming controlling the three
square and you're gonna lose the d4 pawn
on the other hand after Knight to d6 if
you try something like Knights the c5 to
attack this pawn a black will simply
defend King to f7 and then this night
isn't really doing all that much on c5
you will never be able to attack the a7
point it would simply require too many
moves so after 96 the correct reply
Knight see
first was Knight f5 attacking the d4
pawn and the ninth to e to the knight
from E to now guards the d4 pawn nicely
nice to e3
King to F to attacking Fisher's night
nice to see two now and now Fischer is
controlling the d4 pawn very nicely and
not allowing vitamins an e to night to
move King to have three improving the
position of the king and Fischer does
the same King f6 kinga for we have King
to f6 both players simply improve the
position of their kings as that's what
you want to do in the endgame h4 we have
h6 and now h5 not allowing Fischer to
push g5 and if there are some real
beginners here some of you sometimes ask
me in the comments after a move like H
after a move like g5 is played here
how can white play H captures on g6 here
well this is possible something it's a
move called an pass on I believe it's
French for gray you know capturing while
passing by or something like that it's
when black makes a move from from the
front point form the pawns starting
square he moves the pawn two squares
then you are able to capture it either
from for example here or for example if
you had a point here you could capture
it here it would be pretty much the same
if you played g6 and then the pawn
captured it on g6 but it doesn't matter
if you play g5 you can still capture it
even you know as if the point was still
on g6 the only difference is you can
only capture it immediately if you move
the King you will no longer be able to
do this right you know the second time
because Amazon is only player capturing
upon one person is only playable you
know now that this move has been played
so you know just wanted to share that
so after h5 Knights the e1 now Fischer
attacks the g2 pawn g3 is played and
knight back to see to simply controlling
the d4 pawn we have king to g4 now comes
he 5 you know a nice central central
central thrust
D captures on e5 King captures on e5 and
King to f3 now and here Fischer plays
Knight the deef a nice to be for ok this
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine but we should definitely check
out to white and nice the
forecheck doesn't work Knight captures
of course will be winning for black of
course white will not do this King III
and now after captures captures and King
before it's a you know worth exploring
why this doesn't work for black after
King D to kink the e4 is coming and now
white will simply repeat moves king e2
and it will block the black King from
going any further if black is persistent
and keeps on pushing this pawn then
white will simply move the king d3 and
now will start pushing the Queen side
points king d4 a forest coming king c4
and now b5 and here you will have to
move the King back King before and then
it's it will once again be a draw if
white is persistent here and pushes a5
we will then play king c5 and draw this
game but it's very interesting if
instead of this move you play King to be
four then black is lost here why why
black is lost is believe because after
King captures on d3 King captures on a
foreign King c4 you are protecting this
point and after King gave five king c5
black is now you know it is without a
move you have to move black is in
zoobank
and there is nothing you can do here
whatever move you make you will ruin
your position b6 is coming and after
captures captures white is simply much
faster here as you can see after the
Kings approach the pawns captures
captures captures and then white will be
able to push his H pawn all the way to
the promotion so a very nice side line
but it shows why Knight the d4 check
doesn't really do all that much for
black so instead the Fischer goes Knight
to be four attacks the a to pawn we have
nice to see one defending the pawn and
now King to d4 we have g4 here and a
five by Fischer and here whitman plays
Knight to e2 check which is the
strongest move as you can see the King
is controlling the e3 squared the knight
is controlling the c3 square so here
there's the the question whether Fischer
wants to go back with King to e5 or go
King to d3 so before we go back we
should of course check if we can go
forward
so if King to d3 then comes a three
attacking the knight you have
to move the night and the now comes
Knight to f4 check with with a nice
attack against the d5 pawn after King to
c2 then comes b4 white wants to give up
both of the points on the on the Queen
side grab the d5 pawn so here after pawn
captures captures captures and Knight
goes to e6 attacking the g7 point you
will see that white is in time to stop
the past deep one and everything will be
in order
for example King c3 are preparing to
push the D pawn but simply Knight
captures pawn moves Knight here pawn
moves
we have g5h captures and now h6 which
man will also have a nice passed pawn
d2 and after knife to e3 controlling the
queening square this would end up being
a draw so after 93 h7 now comes nice
check King moves and 9th to f7 again
controlling the queening square so now
that both players are controlling the
queening square Knight to f1 will simply
win this pawn and it will be a draw
so after this nice to eat to check
Fischer decided ok King III isn't worth
it I'll go back King to e5 and here with
women simply repeated move or the move
King to see nice to see one and Fischer
did not feel that he could push for any
advantage here and you know as well
there is no way to put for any advantage
here if you move the King he will simply
continue checking him and it's okay I
mean it's equal material a draw not a
bad result here so yeah after three
consecutive wins Fischer draws around 15
and 16 and I'm not gonna spoil anything
but you know here comes was something
that's called Fischer's a legendary
streak after this game but we'll talk
about that more after in in some of my
next videos so yeah that was around 16
of the 1970 palm of America inter-zonal
tournament I do hope you enjoyed it and
that you're enjoying the Bobby Fischer
series so far
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably I'll check a couple of your
suggestions as I've seen you've been
suggesting games a lot
but mostly continuing with the Bobby
Fischer series thank you all and I'll
see you soon